ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BELL GORGEOUS BRADFORD
CABALLERO CHIANG DALLY DODD
THEY'RE ALSO GALGIANI GLAZER
GONZALEZ GROWS HERTZBERG HILL
WEST SO TADO. JACKSON JONES
LEYVA MCGUIRE MITCHELL MONNING
MORLOCK MORALE NIELSEN PAN
PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO SKINNER
STERN BOMBERG Y. CASKEY WIENER
WILK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. WITH THE
MEMBERS IN OUR GUESTS BE ON THE
RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
RISE. WE WILL BE LETTING PRAYER
THIS AFTERNOON BY OUR CHAPLAIN
SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN AFTER
WHICH PLEASE REMAIN STANDING AS
WE ARE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO OUR FLAG BY THE
EVER FABULOUSLY DRESSED SENATOR
MITCHELL. LET US BE CENTERED IN
GOD'S PRESENCE. THE REVEREND
DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR WON SAID. THE ULTIMATE
MEASURE OF A PERSON IS NOT AS
WHERE THEY STAND IN MOMENTS OF
COMFORT AND CONVENIENCE. BUT
WHERE THEY STAND AT TIMES OF
CHALLENGE AND CONTROVERSY. THE
TRUE NEIGHBOR WILL RISK THEIR
POSITION THEIR PRESTIGE AND
EVEN THEIR LIFE FOR THE WELFARE
OF OTHERS. GRACIOUS GOD OF
MERCY AND JUSTICE. AS WE FACE
THE CHALLENGES AND
OPPORTUNITIES OF EACH DAY HELP
US TO STAND FIRM IN OUR TROOPS
WHILE RESPECTING THE DIGNITY OF-OTHER TROOPS. GIVE US THE
COURAGE TO FOREGO OUR OWN
COMFORT AND CONVENIENCE FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THOSE DENIED THEIR
BASIC HUMAN RIGHTS. AND WHEN WE
FAIL MAYWE KNOW YOUR CONTINUED
MERCY AND LOVE WE ASK THIS IN
YOUR NAME A MAN. PLEASE JOIN ME
AS WE SALUTE OUR NATION'S FLAG
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH
IT STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THE P. C. SO
WE. GOOD AFTERNOON COLLEAGUES
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE DIRECTLY TO
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED UNDER MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES SEEING
NONE WE MOVE ON TO THE
INTRODUCTION AND FIRST READING
OF BILLS MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL. TEN
FORTY FORTY ONE FORTY TWO FORTY
THREE FORTY FOUR FORTY FIVE
FORTY SIX FORTY SEVE FIFTY
NINE TEN SIXTEEN SIXTY ONE
FIRST READING OF BILLS WILL BE
DEEMED COMPLETED. BEFORE WE GO
TO CONSIDERATION ALL OF THE
DAILY FILE LET'S GO BACK TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR AND
SENATOR HILL. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES- PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING IN ONE OF
THE NEWEST COUNCIL MEMBERS FROM
THE CITY OF FOSTER CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER RISHA AWASH THE- MEASURE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME.
ALL EGGS A WARM WELCOME TO OUR
FAMILY MEMBER. WE SHOULD-
FAMILY OR HEAR FROM FOSTER CITY
VISIT IN THE CAPITALS OF THANK
YOU. WELCOME. WE ARE NOW GOING
TO GO TO CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE. STARTING WITH FILE
ITEM EIGHT. SENATOR BRADFORD TO
ARE YOU PREPARE. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION SEVENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR BRADFORD RELATIVE TO
BLACK HISTORY MONTH SENATOR
BRADFORD THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I STAND TODAY TO
PRESENT SR SEVENTY FOUR THE
BLACK HISTORY MONTH RESOLUTION
AND AS VICE YEAR I'M HONORED TO
PRESENT THIS VICE CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS. THE
CAUCUS IS BORN OUT OF THE NEED
TO BOLSTER AND EMPOWER THE
COLLECTIVE VOICE OF BLACK
ELECTED OFFICIALS IN THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE FIFTY
TWO YEARS AGO TODAY WE HONOR
OUR HERITAGE AND CELEBRATE OUR
LEGACY WE STAND ON THE
SHOULDERS OF FIGURES SUCH AS
FREDERICK ROBERTS THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN TO BE ELECTED
HERE IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE OR NAME THAT MANY
OF YOU PROBABLY DON'T KNOW
ALEXANDER TWILIGHT. THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN TO EVER BE
ELECTED IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES PRIOR TO THE
CIVIL WAR. THE HERE IN CONCERT
OF AMERICANS. OF AFRICAN
DESCENT MAY. HAVE MADE TO HELP
SHAPE THE CULTURE ACADEMIC
SOCIAL ECONOMIC AND MORE-
TRIBUTES OF A NATION IS
UNDENIABLE. HAVE YOU EVER
THOUGHT ABOUT WHAT IT WOULD BE
LIKE IF THERE WERE NO AFTER
AMERICANS. HAVE YOU MARVELED AT
THIS LIGHT IT CHAMBER. BUT IF
IT WAS NOT FOR. LEWIS LATIMER
WHO INVENTED THE FILAMENT OF
THE LIGHT BUT WE PROBABLY WOULD
BE HERE IN CANDLE LIGHT OR THE
DARK MANY BELIEVE IT WAS THOMAS
EDISON BUT IT WAS LEWIS LATIMER.
OR HAVE YOU EVER THOUGHT ABOUT
GETTING ON THE ELEVATOR IN
GOING UP AND DOWN THIS BUILDING
AND MANY OTHER BUILDINGS WHOSE
INVENTION OF ALEXANDER MILES.
MANY OF AS A TRIBUTE THE CARD-CHEN TO- ILL I WHITLEY BUT IT
WAS A LARGER- MCCOURT NOW I'M
I'M SORRY I'M MISSING MY- I
WILL COME BACK TO THAT BUT THE
KIND CHEN. AND THE GOLF TEE
FORD GUY LIKE ME WHO PLAYS GOLF
IT WAS GEORGE FRANK GRANT WHO
INVENTED THAT. AND SO MUCH MORE
BUT TODAY BUT EVERY DAY WE
CELEBRATE THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS
AND TALENTS AND ACHIEVEMENTS
AND CONTRIBUTIONS OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS. I AM OFTEN FACE WITH
THE STARK CONTRAST THAT AS
AMERICA IT IS LEARNING. AND THE
PROGRESSIONS IN COMING TO TERMS
WITH THE PAST AND HOW TO DIRECT
THE FUTURE WHEN IT COMES TO
EQUALITY IN HILL WE ARE STILL A
WORK IN PROGRESS IN FACT I
THINK OF THE TIME WHEN I WAS
ELECTED AS THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN. CITY COUNCILMAN IN
THE CITY OF GARDENA IN NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN IN A COMMENT WAS
MADE THIS IS THE DARKEST DAY IN
THE HISTORY OF THE CITY OF
GARDENA. MEMBERS WE HAVE AN
INTERNAL OBLIGATION AS
LEGISLATIVE BODY TO PROMOTE
RACIAL HARMONY AND THE RIGHT
THE HISTORIC WRONGS OF RACES
POLICIES IN EDUCATION HOUSING
LENDING AND POLICING. WE MUST
BE VOTE VILLAGE OF ANTS AND
STEADFAST IN OUR PURSUIT OF
EQUALITY. EQUITY FOR EDUCATION
ECONOMICS AND SOCIAL JUSTICE WE
SHOULD ALSO BE FIRM IN OUR
FIGHT. FOR REPARATIONS FOR THE
GENERATIONS OF ANY QUALITY AND
ANY EQUITY OF AFRICAN AMERICANS
HAVE FACED IN THIS COUNTRY
WITHOUT RECOGNITION A
RESTITUTION FOR THE RACISM THAT
HAS BEEN SERVED AS THE BEDROCK
OF AMERICA WE CAN NEVER HOPE TO
TRULY HAVE A LEVEL FOOTING AND
IN SOCIETY. RACISM IS SO
INGRAINED IN OUR NATION'S FIVE
FOUNDATION THAT IS NOT ENOUGH
TO SIMPLY SAY THAT YOU'RE NOT A
RACIST INSTEAD WE MUST MAKE THE
COMMITMENT AND A FIRM THAT
WE'RE ANTI RACISM RACES AND WE
SUPPORT. EQUALITY FOR EVERYBODY
BLACK HISTORY IS A IS AN
AMERICAN HISTORY AND IT TELLS A
STORY- WHAT IT MEANS TO BE IN
AMERICA FROM SLAVERY TO THE
WHITE HOUSE HANDS THAT ONCE
PICKED COTTON CAN NOW SELECT
PRESIDENT'S MANITOU WE TRULY
EMBRACE OUR PASS AND MAKE THE
COMMITMENT TO SECURE OUR FUTURE
CAN WE TRULY APPRECIATE THE
GREATNESS AND POTENTIAL OF OUR
NATION. I WANT TO THANK YOU AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
ON S. R. SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU
SENATOR BRADFORD DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM SENATOR
PAM. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS ON AS VICE CHAIR OF
THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. OF SR SEVENTY
FOUR. CELEBRATE BLACK HISTORY
MONTH I THANK MY GOOD FRIEND
GUARDINO FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. EACH FEBRUARY WE
REFLECTED RECOGNIZE THE
SIGNIFICANCE BLACK COMMUNITIES
HAVE HAD IN MAKING THE UNITED
STATES THE COUNTRY IT IS TODAY.
AND AS IS POINTED OUT IN THE
OPENING MANY FACETS OUR LIVES
HAVE BEEN SHAPED BY AFTER
AMERICAN INVENTORS AND
INNOVATORS. IN FACT ONE OF THE
INNOVATIONS FROM. AFTER
AMERICANS ACTUALLY THE VERY
TERM ASIAN AMERICAN. WHICH WAS
INSPIRED BY THE BLACK POWER
MOVEMENT AND PROTESTS AGAINST
THE VIETNAM WAR. IT WAS IN FACT
COINED IN NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT
SIGNIFY COLLECTIVE POWER SO-
THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT PART OF
BOTH- BLACK HISTORY AND EIGHTY
I HISTORY. AND CERTAINLY AS AN
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER- I
RECOGNIZE HOW AFTER AMERICANS
WERE PIONEERS IN IN THE
VANGUARD FOR CIVIL RIGHTS. IN
THE UNITED STATES CONFRONTED
WITH DISCRIMINATION
DISENFRANCHISEMENT IN THE POLLS
AFTER AMERICAN CIVIL RIGHTS
LEADERS FOUGHT FOR THE PASSAGE
OF THE VOTING RIGHTS ACT OF
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE WHICH
ADVANCED BETTER ACCESSIBILITY
FOR ALL AMERICANS. SO AS WE
COMMEMORATE BLACK HISTORY MONTH
WE HONOR THE COURAGEOUS
INDIVIDUALS AND GROUPS TO PAVE
THE WAY FOR MORE EQUITABLE
FUTURE AND CONTINUE TO LIKE TO
SEE IN THE FIGHT FOR JUSTICE.
AND CERTAINLY FOR THE- FOR THE
API COMMUNITY WE HAVE A LOT TO
LEARN FROM STUDYING BLACK
HISTORY SO THIS IS A ESSENTIAL
HISTORY FOR ALL AMERICANS AND-
PARTICULARLY FOR THE ATI
COMEDIAS WELL I STRONG STANCE
SUPPORT THIS ARE SEVENTY FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR.
WE ARIZA IN SUPPORT OF SR
SEVENTY FOUR- AS CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE LGBT Q. CAUCUS I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- I
SPECIFICALLY CHOSE ONE TWO
POINT TO OUR BROKEN CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM WHICH IS A
SYSTEM- THAT FOR EVER HAS BEEN
USED AS A TOOL OF OPPRESSION-
AGAINST- ARE- AGAINST BLACK
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY- AND
ALSO AGAINST- LGBT Q. PEOPLE
WHEN YOU CRIMINALIZE PEOPLE
IT'S A WAY OF KEEPING PEOPLE
DOWN- KEEPING COMMUNITIES ON
THE DEFENSE AND COMPLIANCE AND-
CRUSHING A COMMUNITY UNDER-
YOUR HEEL AND THAT AS WHAT OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM HAS
DONE- TO- THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY FOREVER- AT TWO LGBT
Q. PEOPLE. AND A LOT MONTH OF
ABLE TO COME TOGETHER ARE-
BLOCK CAUCUS AND ARE ALSO BE TO
CAUCUS- TO ASK- GOVERNOR
NEWSOME- TO GRANT A POSTHUMOUS
PARDON- TO BAYARD RUSTIN WHO IS
A KEY LEADER IN THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT WHO IS A BLACK-
GAME MAN- WHO WAS ARRESTED I AM
PASADENA FOR HAVING CONSENSUAL
SEX- TO WAIT IN THE WHITE MEN
WERE LISTED AS VICTIMS ON THE
POLICE ARE AND BEAR ROBSON WAS
PROSECUTED AND BANG. IN JAIL
FOR HAVING CAN SEX WAS ON THE
SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY AND WAS
ULTIMATELY BY SIGNIFICANTLY
PUSHED OUT OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT STRONG THURMAN IN THE
SENATE MADE AN ISSUE OF IT- IT
WAS JUST A TERRIBLE THING FOR
SOMEONE WHO WAS SUCH A
PROFOUNDLY IMPORTANT LEADER- IN
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT AND
HE WAS A TAX- A BLACK MAN. WHO
STEP UP FOR HIS COMMUNITY. AND
HE WAS A TOP BECAUSE HE WAS A
GAME AND I WANT TO. FIRST OF
ALL PUBLIC BANG THE BLOCK FOR
STANDING WITH US IN WORKING TO
ASK THE GOVERNOR TO MISTER
RUSTIN SO THAT HE CAN- WE CAN
FULLY MBRACE AND HOPEFULLY
REMIND PEOPLE OF THE ROLE THAT
HE PLAYED AS A BLACK CAME OUT
OF- AND THE GOVERNOR DID GRANT
A PARDON- AND I WENT OUT.
PUBLICLY THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR
DOING THAT AND ALSO PUBLICLY
THANK HIM FOR GOING BEYOND WHAT
WE REQUESTED AND SETTING UP A
PROCESS FOR OTHER LGBTQ PEOPLE
WHO'VE BEEN CRIMINALIZED AND
CONVICTED. AND PLACED ON THE
SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY FOR YEARS
BECAUSE THE SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRY HAS ALWAYS BEEN A TOOL
OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
TO DESTROY LGBTQ PEOPLE- HE
SAID OF A PROCESS FOR PEOPLE TO
COME FORWARD. AND ALSO SEE
PARDONS- SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SENATOR WINNER
SENATOR MORLOCK. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SR SEVENTY FOUR AND-
AS THE AUTHOR MENTIONED WE HAVE
A WONDERFUL HISTORY OF BLACK
ELECTED OFFICIALS IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AYE COMPROMISE
SESQUI CENTENNIAL STANDPOINT
JUST WANNA SHARE SOME PARTS
FROM ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
YEARS AGO- ON FEBRUARY TWENTY
FIVE ALMOST A WEEK FROM TODAY
ON EIGHTY IN EIGHTEEN SEVENTY.
HI ROOM ARE REBELS TOOK OVER
THE OATH OF OFFICE AS THE FIRST
BLACK UNITED STATES SENATOR
REPRESENTING THE STATE OF
MISSISSIPPI HE WAS- ORDAINED AS
A MINISTER. IN THE AFRICAN
METHODIST EPISCOPAL CHURCH AMY
WORKING AS AN ITINERANT
PREACHER BACK IN EIGHTEEN FORTY
FIVE. HE PARTICIPATED IN THE
CIVIL WAR ORGANIZING TWO BLACK
REGIMENTS FOR THE UNION ARMY.
HE ALSO FOUGHT FOR THE UNION AT
THE BATTLE OF VICKSBURG. AFTER
THE WAR HE SETTLED IN NATCHEZ
MISSISSIPPI WITH HIS WIFEAND
DAUGHTERS AND CONTINUED HIS
CAREER IN THE CLERGY. HE
QUICKLY GREW TO BE A RESPECTED
MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY KNOWN
FOR HIS KEEN. INTELLIGENCE IN
OR TORKEL SKILLS. ALTHOUGH HE
HAD NO PREVIOUS GOVERNMENT
EXPERIENCE REBELS GARNERED
ENOUGH COMMUNITY SUPPORT TO WIN
ELECTION TO THE POSITION OF
ALDERMAN IN EIGHTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT. RING THE FIRST PHASE OF
RECONSTRUCTION HE THEN SERVED
BRIEFLY IN THE MISSISSIPPI
STATE SENATE. IN EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY THE STATE CONGRESS
SELECTED REBELS THE BILL OF
BACON SEAT IN THE UNITED STATES
SENATE. DEBATE SURROUNDING HIS
ELIGIBILITY HINGED ON THE
EIGHTEEN FIFTY SEVEN DRED SCOTT
DECISION WHICH PRECLUDED
AFRICAN AMERICAN CITIZENSHIP.
THE DECISION WAS EFFECTIVELY
REVERSED BY THE RATIFICATION OF
THE FOURTEENTH AMENDMENT AFTER
THE CIVIL WAR. DEMOCRATS ARGUED
THAT REBELS DID NOT MEET THE
NINE YOUR CITIZENSHIP
REQUIREMENT TO HOLD
CONGRESSIONAL OFFICE. GIVEN IS
IN A BELGIAN IN ELIGIBILITY
PERCENT IT'S AN SHIP THROUGH
THE WAR YEARS. ULTIMATELY
REBELS AND HIS REPUBLICAN
ALLIES. PREVAILED BY CITING
REBELS MIXED RACE BACKGROUND
AND REBELS BECAME THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN TO SERVE IN
THE UNITED STATES SENATE. HIS
APPOINTMENT WAS PARTICULARLY
SYMBOLIC IN THAT THE SEAT HE
OCCUPIED. HAD PREVIOUSLY
BELONGED TO JEFFERSON DAVIS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CONFEDERACY.
DURING HIS TIME IN WASHINGTON
THE PRESS PRAISED REBELS FOR IS
WELL CRAFTED SPEECHES AND
DIPLOMATIC APPROACH TO ATTEND
TO CONGRESSIONAL ENVIRONMENT.
HIS SIGNATURE ISSUE WAS CIVIL
RIGHTS INCLUDING THE
INTEGRATION OF SCHOOLS AND
EQUAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR BLACK
WORKERS. REVELS URGED THE
MODERATE VIEW ON THE
RESTORATION OF CONFEDERATE
CITIZENSHIP. WHILE THE RADICAL
REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS CALLED
FOR HARSH PUNISHMENTS TO BE
METED OUT. TO CIVIL WAR REBELS
SENATOR REBELS. TOOK A MILDER
VIEW HE ARGUED FOR THE
IMMEDIATE RESTORATION OF
CITIZENSHIP THE FORMER
CONFEDERATES ALONG WITH THE
SECURITY. IN FRANCHISE MEANT
EDUCATION EMPLOYMENT
ELIGIBILITY OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS. REBELS RESIGNED FROM
THE SENATE AFTER YEAR TO ACCEPT
THE PRESIDENCY OF ALCORN
AGRICULTURAL AND MECHANICAL
COLLEGE LOCATED IN CLAIBORNE
COUNTY MISSISSIPPI HE ALSO
SERVED AS AN INSTRUCTOR AND
PHILOSOPHY THIS POSITION AT THE
HISTORICALLY BLACK ALCORN
ALLOWED REBELS TO DIRECTLY
PARTICIPATE IN THE INTELLECTUAL
ENRICHMENT OF AFRICAN AMERICANS
THE CAUSE FOR WHICH HE HAD
FOUGHT WHILE SERVING IN THE
SENATE. IN ADDITION TO HIS
ADMINISTRATIVE AND TEACHING
ROLES REBELS REMAINED INVOLVED
WITH THE METHODIST CHURCH
CONTINUE TO PREACH PUBLICLY
UNTIL THE END OF HIS LIFE
REBELS DIED ON JANUARY
SIXTEENTH NINETEEN OH ONE WHILE
ATTENDING A MEETING OF
METHODIST MINISTERS IN ABERDEEN
MISSISSIPPI. WE'RE JUST PROUD
OF A GREAT HIS HISTORY IN THIS
NATION AND THE STATE AND I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT SR
SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SENATOR
MORE LARGE SENATOR TO RAZA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- AS VICE
CHAIR AND AS A STATE SENATOR I
RISE TO. SUPPORT UP. SR SEVENTY
FOUR AND I THANK THE AUTHOR-
YES A BLACK HISTORY MONTH IS AN
IMPORTANT TIME TO CELEBRATE.
AND REFLECT ON THE
EXTRAORDINARY TALENTS
ACHIEVEMENTS AND CONTRIBUTIONS
OF AFRICAN AMERICANS. OF I WANT
TO SAY THAT THE CONTRIBUTIONS
ON THE SUCCESS OF. ARE NOT ONLY
FOR OUR STATE AND OUR NATION
BUT IN PARTICULAR FR THE
LATINO COMMUNITY FOR INSTANCE
THURGOOD MARSHALL'S LEGAL WORK.
ESTABLISH CIVIL AND POLITICAL
RIGHTS THEY CONTINUED TO BE
VITAL TODAY TO THE COMMUNITY
WHILE HE MAY BE BEST REMEMBERED
FOR ARGUING AGAINST THE
SEPARATE BUT EQUAL DOCTRINE IN
THE BROWN VERSUS BOARD OF
EDUCATION THAT CASE LAID THE
FOUNDATION FOR COUNTLESS. MANY
MANY MORE LEGAL ADVANCEMENTS
FOR DECADES TO COME. DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING. ESTABLISHED
HIMSELF AS A LEADER OF THIS
NATION BECAUSE OF HIS
COMMITMENT TO NONVIOLENCE ANY
INSPIRED MOVEMENTS OF PEOPLE
INCLUDING THE LATINO COMMUNITY
THE FIGHT FOR OUR ISSUES TO
FIGHT FOR ISSUES WHETHER IS
EDUCATION OR FARMWORKERS DIDN'T
MATTER FOR THE JUST THE RIGHT
TO BE TREATED EQUALLY. THROUGH
A NON VIOLENT MEANS. COLLEAGUES
IS THAT THESE ARE JUST TWO
EXAMPLES OF THE EXTRAORDINARY
WAY IN WHICH AMERICANS. WHOSE
LIVEWORK SITES SUCH A PROFOUND
GRATEFUL FOR THE LEADERSHIP THE
INSPIRATION THE SACRIFICE AND
THE STRUGGLE OF OUR AFRICAN
AMERICAN SISTERS AND BROTHERS
SO. IN HONOR OF THOSE WHO WE'VE
THIS EXTRAORDINARY TAPESTRY WE
CALL ON YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
RESOLUTION THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR ALSO SENATOR LEYVA.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON A MEMBERS AS THE
CHAIR THE LEGISLATIVE- CAUCUS
LEGISLATE WOMEN'S CAUCUS I RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S. R. FOR
A SEVENTY FOUR I WANT TO THINK
OF THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THE
GREEN BOOK FOR ALL OF US
HOPEFULLY EVERYONE SAW THE
MOVIE. BUT YOU KNOW WE SEE
BOOKS WE GET BOOKS LIKE THIS WE
SEE THINGS LIKE THIS AND YOUR I
DIDN'T GROW UP IN A HOUSE LIKE
THIS I DIDN'T GROW UP IN A
HOUSE WHERE WE TREAT PEOPLE
DIFFERENTLY BECAUSE OF THE
COLOR OF THEIR SKIN AND IT'S
STILL SHOCKING TO ME. THAT THIS
WAS NEEDED AND IT'S SHOCKING TO
ME THAT EVEN TODAY RACISM
EXISTS THE WAY IT DOES BUT IT
MAKES ME HAPPY HAPPY THAT AS A
LEGISLATOR I HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE ON THINGS
HOPEFULLY THAT WILL LESSEN-
RACISM BUT WE ALWAYS LIKE TO IN
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS ON BLACK
HISTORY MONTH RECOGNIZE SOME
OUTSTANDING WOMEN. AND MANY OF
US KNOW THAT MANY CONTENTIOUS
ELECTIONS OVER THE PAST DECADE
HAVE BEEN HAVE BEEN DECIDED
BECAUSE BLACK WOMEN BANDED
TOGETHER AND MADE THE RIGHT
THING HAPPENED. HELLO BAKER WAS
AN AFRICAN AMERICAN CIVIL AND
HUMAN RIGHTS ACTIVIST WHO IS
KNOWN FOR SHINING A LIGHT ON
THE SEXISM THAT EXISTED WITHIN
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT TODAY
THE ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS WORKS NATIONWIDE TO RE
DIRECT RESOURCES AWAY FROM
PRISONS AND PUNISHMENT AND
TOWARDS OPPORTUNITIES AND HELP
COMMUNITIES GROW AND A HEALTHY
AND STRONG MANNER. DOROTHY
HEIGHT WORKED AS A CIVIL RIGHTS
AND WOMEN'S ACTIVIST SHE
FOCUSED ON ISSUES AFFECTING
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMEN
INCLUDING UNEMPLOYMENT
ILLITERACY AND VOTER AWARENESS
THROUGH CITIZEN EDUCATION
WORKSHOP. SHE WOULD LATER GO ON
TO BE THE DIRECTOR THE HEAD
START. AN ALUM MAYA VICE. OF
THE LUTHER KING JUNIOR CENTER
FOR NONVIOLENT SOCIAL CHANGE IN
ATLANTA. AND THE DIRECTOR OF
STUDENT ACTIVITIES AT CORNELL
IN NINETEEN NINETY FOUR SHE
RECEIVED THE PRESIDENTIAL MEDAL
OF FREEDOM. AND TEN YEARS LATER
HE RECEIVED THE CONGRESSIONAL
GOLD MEDAL AS WE CELEBRATE
BLACK HISTORY MONTH WELL THE
SUPPLY THE BRAVERY AND STRENGTH
OF THESE TRAILBLAZING WOMEN.
AND SO MANY OTHERS AND IT
KNOWLEDGE HOW MUCH MORE WORK
NEEDS TO BE DONE SO THAT WE
CONTINUE TO OPEN OPPORTUNITIES
FOR EVERYONE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR LABOR SENATOR ALAN.
MEMBERS SAYS CHAIR OF OUR LIVES
OF JEWISH CAUCUS I WANT TO ADD
MY VOICE OF SUPPORT FOR SR
SEVENTY FOUR. AND SAY HOW PROUD
OUR COMMUNITY IS OF THE WORK
THAT ARE TO COMMITTEES OF DONE
TOGETHER ON VOTING RIGHTS ON
CIVIL RIGHTS. ON SO MANY
DIFFERENT AREAS A PARTNERSHIP-
YOU KNOW WHAT I WILL ALSO SAY
THAT I'M ONE OF THE INTERESTING
THINGS. THAT HAS BEEN COMING
UP- IT RECENTLY IS AS OUR AS
OUR SOCIETY BECOMES MORE
COMPLEX MORE DIVERSE. AS
THERE'S ALL SORTS OF MINGLING
OF CULTURES AND PEOPLES ARE
THERE SO MANY NEW TYPES OF
STORIES THAT HAVE EMERGED THAT
CHAU INTERSECTION ALLERGY-
WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF THE
DEBATE OVER ETHNIC STUDIES I
WAS AT THE INSTRUCTIONAL
QUALITY COMMISSION AND WE HAD A
NUMBER OF. OF BLACK JEWS WHO
CAME IN TO SPEAK ABOUT THEIR
EXPERIENCES USE OF COLOR. IT'S
NOT JUST ROD CAREW AND SAMMY
DAVIS JUNIOR- THERE'S A LOT OF
US A LOT OF FOLKS TO- OF
EMBRACE THE THAT USE ME THEY
WERE BORN IN JEWISH FAITH. WHO
COME FROM ARCHIMEDES OF COLOR
HERE AND CALIFORNIA. AND I ALSO
POINT OUT ON OUR RECENT TRIP TO
ISRAEL THE JEWISH CAUCUS THAT
WE WHICH INVOLVED MEMBERS OF
THE BLACK CAUCUS. WE'RE LIVE IS
A COUPLE LITTLE TOWN THAT HAD A
SIZEABLE AFRICAN JEWISH
COMMUNITY. AND THAT WAS A IS A
REALLY MIND BLOWING EXPERIENCE
FOR EVERYONE INVOLVED LEARNING
ABOUT THE STORY. SO FOR ME IT
IT JUST REMINDS US OF OUR OF
ALL THE INTERSECTIONS THAT
EXIST WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES.
HI THE FACT THAT. WE ARE SO
CLOSE CONNECTED AND I KNOW THAT
THERE IS JUST A- DEEP SENSE OF
SOLID. BETWEEN JEWISH. AND I
AMERICAN CAN GIVEN HOW. MUCH
ARE FOR. AND SOME ASK DIED TO.
FIGHTING FOR THE OF RIGHTS. AND
AN AND BEST HERE IN IN IN IN I.
STATES OF AMERICA SO WE- WITH
OUR- AND IN RUSSIA BLACK. CAR
AND AT CREATOR THE ROOM MADE BY.
AS PROUD. NOW WE HAVE TO KEEP
FIVE A IS. THE THIS THAT IS A-
MY SO. WHAT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT I
APPRECIATE YOU YOU KNOW
COLLEAGUES. I'VE HEARD PEOPLE-
THANK YOU KNOW FIFTY WHERE WHAT
ARE WE CELEBRATING BLACK
HISTORY MONTH THE SHORTEST
MONTH. THE SHORTEST MONTH OF
THE YEAR AND WHILE THAT
SOMETIMES IS AMUSING THERE'S A
HUGE THERE'S A REASON WHY
CARTAGENA IT'S IN SELECTED
FEBRUARY FEBRUARY HAPPEN TO BE
IN ORIGINALLY OF COURSE IT WAS
NEGRO HISTORY WEEK. BUT HE
SELECTED FEBRUARY. MOST
INTENTIONALLY FEBRUARY IS THE
BIRTH MONTH OF BOTH- PRESIDENT
ABRAHAM LINCOLN. WE NOW THE
RELEVANCE HE PLAYS IN. OUR
LIVES AS BLACK PEOPLE AS WELL
AS FREDERICK DOUGLASS AS OF
FEBRUARY WAS SELECTED VERY
INTENTIONALLY TO CREATE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PAUSE AND TALK
ABOUT THE RELEVANCE. THAT
NEGROES BLACKS AFTER AMERICANS
HAVE HAD IN THIS COUNTRY OVER
TIME. CASE IN POINT A HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE YEARS AGO. THE
THIRTEENTH AMENDMENT WHICH
ABOLISHED SLAVERY WAS RATIFIED
BY THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY YEARS AGO
THE FIFTEENTH AMENDMENT WHICH
GAVE BLACK MEN THE RIGHT TO
VOTE WAS RATIFIED. ONE HUNDRED
YEARS AGO THE NINETEENTH
AMENDMENT WHICH FINALLY GAVE
BLACK WOMEN THE RIGHT TO VOTE
WAS RATIFIED. SIXTY SIX YEARS
AGO THE US SUPREME COURT RULED
THAT RACIAL SEGREGATION AT
PUBLIC SCHOOLS WAS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL. FIFTY SIX
YEARS AGO THE CIVIL RIGHTS ACT
WAS PASSED WHICH OUTLAWED
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON RACE.
THAT'S WHERE THE GREEN BOOK
THAT I'M URE MY COLLEAGUE WILL
EXPLAIN TO THE LATER. WAS
IMPORTANT FOR BLACK PEOPLE TO
STAY SAFE AS THEY TRAVEL ACROSS
STATE LINES KNOWING PLACES THAT
THEY COULD STAY SAFELY. AND
WHILE THE ADDITION WE'VE SHARED
WITH YOU WITH THE NINETEEN
FORTY ADDITION PLEASE
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS BOOK
CONTINUE TO BE PUBLISHED FOR
YEARS AND YEARS AFTER NINETEEN
FORTY. FIFTY THREE YEARS AGO
THE US SUPREME COURT MADE.
INTERRACIAL MARRIAGE LEGAL. AND
EVERY YEAR ON THIS FLOOR OF
THIS HOUSE WE HAVE PASSED BILLS
TO TRY TO CREATE A SENSE OF
EQUITY AND PARITY FOR BOTH
STUDENTS FOR BLACK PEOPLE IN
THE WORKPLACE IN HOW YOU IN HOW
WE CHOOSE TO WEAR OUR HAIR.
EXCEPT A- MY HOPE IS THAT A
VOTE FOR THIS RESOLUTION IS A
CONTINUED COMMITMENT. TO US
CONTINUING THE GOOD WORK THAT
HAS COME BEFORE US AND WORK
THAT WE MUST CONTINUE.
COLLEAGUES LET US OUT OF THE
PAST COUPLE OF THE PRESENT AND
ROOT FOR THE FUTURE I URGE AN
AYE VOTE ON SENATE RESOLUTION
SEVENTY FOUR. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL SEEING NO FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SENATOR
BRADFORD TO YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES TO. LENT
THEIR VOICES TO THIS IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION AND AS I STATED IN
THE BEGINNING BLACK HISTORY IS
AMERICAN HISTORY. AND IT'S
SOMEWHAT SAD THAT WE HAVE TO
STAND UP ONCE A YEAR AND
RECOGNIZE THE CONTRIBUTIONS
THAT AFRICAN AMERICANS OF MAY
TO THIS COUNTRY FOR OVER FOUR
HUNDRED YEARS. AND LAST YEAR WE
HAD A CONTENTIOUS DEBATE ALLEN
BOTH HOUSES ABOUT A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO- AUTHORED AS IT
RELATES TO VACCINATIONS. BUT IF
WE ARE WHERE THE FIRST
VACCINATION OR NOT ELECTION
FROM DISEASE WAS BY AFRICA HERE
IN BOSTON. AND SEVENTEEN TWENTY
ONE. AND MANY PEOPLE WERE
OUTRAGED BUT IT'S SAVED
HUNDREDS OF NOT THOUSANDS OF
LIVES IN BOSTON IN SEVENTEEN
TWENTY ONE. THE OF IS KNOWN
PLENTY PEOPLE WHO'VE NEEDED A
BLOOD TRANSFUSION. WE HAVE TO
THANK- CHARLES R. DREW A BLACK
POSITION WHO LOST HIS LIFE
BECAUSE HE DIED IN A HOSPITAL
HE BLED TO DEATH BECAUSE THEY
WOULD NOT SERVE HIM. BECAUSE IT
WAS A WHITE HOSPITAL. AND FOR
ALL OF US WHO ARE FANS OF
WESTERNS AND THE LONG RANGER
AND HIS GOOD FRIEND TANTO WELL
IF YOU REALLY KNOW HISTORY THAT
LONE RANGER WAS A BLACK COWBOY
WHO BECAME A US MARSHAL AND IS
TRAVELING COMPANION WAS A
NATIVE AMERICAN AND HE WROTE A
WHITE HORSE. BUT WE NEVER GOT
CREDIT FOR THAT. AS I WAS
STATING ABOUT THE KANJI AND ELI
WHITNEY IS THE ONE WHO'S CREDIT
AWAITED BUT BELIEVE ME IT WAS A
SLAVE. THAT DESIGNED THE
TECHNIQUE COULD CALM THE SEATS
AND THAT BORN OUT OF THE- ART
OF THE COD BECAUSE AGAIN. NO
SLAVE MASTER OR I SHOULD SAY
WHITE GUY WOULD BE CONCERNED
ABOUT MAKING LABOR ANY EASIER
IT WAS THE SLAVE WHO WAS DOING
THIS LABOR WAS TRYING TO BE AN
AN INNOVATIVE IN MAKING THEIR-
PASS A LITTLE BIT EASIER THAT'S
WHY THEY INVENTED. THE ELEVATOR
BECAUSE THEY WERE LIFTING
THINGS UP IN DOWN IN BUILDINGS
AND THE INNOVATIONS OF AFTER
AMERICANS GO ON AND ON FOR US
WHO CALL OURSELVES
ENVIRONMENTALISTS. MANY SAY THE
FIRST ENVIRONMENTALISTS IN THIS
COUNTRY WAS GEORGE WASHINGTON
CARVER WHO. WANTED TO SIR-
RESTORES SOIL PRESERVATION ANY
INCURRED SOUTHERN FARMERS TO
STOP PLANNING CORPS COTTON. AND
PLANT PEANUTS. AND SWEET POTATO
THAT'S THIS RESTORED THE
NUTRIENTS BACK INTO THE SOIL.
AND THIS WAS IN THE EARLY
NINETEEN HUNDREDS WE CAN GO ON
AND ON AND ON. EVEN THOSE WHO
ARE FANS OF BETTY BOOP. THE
FAMOUS CARTOON FROM THE
NINETEEN THIRTIES. WELL IT WAS
A SINGER BY THE NAME OF ESTHER
JONES THAT WAS KNOWN AS BABY
ASTOR WHO WAS THE ORIGINAL.
FIGURE FOR CREATING THAT IMAGE
BUT IT WAS A- WHITE SINGER A
FEW YEARS LATER WHO THOUGHT. MS
JONES PERFORMING AND SHE COPIED
HER STYLE WITH THE BOOK-
PRODUCED IN OUR SEEING AND
THEY'RE INCLINED WENT AND THEN
THEY AND I CAME OUT WITH THE
CARTOON HELLING KLEIN KANE I
SHOULD SAY SHE FILE LAWSUITS
THE AN INFRINGEMENT ON HER
IMAGE. AND THE COURTS ROUTE
THIS IS NO YOU'RE NOT THE
ORIGINATOR OF THIS IMAGE EVEN
THOUGH ESTHER JONES NEVER GOT
CREDIT FOR CREATING THE IMAGE
IN ANY EVER LIKENESS BATES THE
NIGHT MRS KAYNE SUIT FOR TRYING
TO CLAIM THAT SHE WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR. IN MANY WAYS
MY FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES WE
SAY WE DID IT. BUT AMERICANS
HIT IT THEY'VE HIDDEN MANY OF
OUR ACCOMPLISHMENTS IN THIS
COUNTRY THEY'VE HIDDEN IT BY
NOT PUT IT IN BOOKS FORCED TO
LEARN THEY'VE HIDDEN IT BY THE
NINE ETHNIC STUDIES AND OUR
SCHOOLS SOMETHING THAT WE WILL
BE DISSIPATING HERE IN THIS
CHAMBER SOON. THEY'VE DONE IT
BY- PERSON THEY DONE IT BY ALL
THE HORRIBLE THINGS THAT WE'RE
ALL AWARE OF BUT WE STAND HERE
TODAY KNOWING THAT THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF MADE THIS
COUNTRY GREAT. THE
CONTRIBUTIONS. THAT HAVE MADE
THIS COUNTRY GREAT ARE STILL
BEING MADE BY NOT ONLY AFTER
AMERICANS BUT BUT ALL PEOPLE.
AND WE DO I THINK OF MY
COLLEAGUE THE CHAIR OF THE
JEWISH CAUCUS BECAUSE- IN THE
LATE THIRTIES WHEN. H. B. C.
USE WERE AT THEIR HIGH GROWTH
IT WAS THE JEWISH PROFESSORS
THAT WORK KICKED OUT OF GERMANY
AND AUSTRIA WHO CAME TO THE H.
B. C. USE AND THEY TAUGHT
CLASSES AND THEY BECAME-
RESIDENT PROFESSORS AT THESE H.
B. C. USE SO THERE'S BEEN A
LONG. PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY. BUT AGAIN
MEMBERS. WE HAVE TO THINK
CARTER G. WHAT'S IN FOR HIS
VISION AND AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LA STATED ALL OF YOU HAVE BEEN
GIVING THE GREEN BOOK. THIS WAS
THE BIBLE FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS
SOME SEVENTY YEARS AGO IF THEY
WANT TO TRAVERSE THIS COUNTRY
AND DO IT SAFELY. THIS WAS THE
BIBLE WHERE THEY COULD STAY
WHERE THEY COULD KEY. WHERE
THEY COULD FILL THEIR CAR.
WHETHER THE KIDS SEEK REFUGE
YOU NAME IT THIS WAS IT SO I
HOPE YOU TAKE IT I HOPE YOU
LOOK AT IT IN AS ONE OF MY
COLLEGE WAS REALLY LOOKING AT
SOME OF THE PLACES THAT EXISTED
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY WAS ONLY
TO. THAT EXISTED IN CENTRAL
VALLEY IN THIS PUBLICATION BUT
I STAND HERE TO SAY HONOR. TO
RECOGNIZE THE CONTRIBUTIONS AND
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE ARE
STILL MORE TO BE MADE BUT AGAIN
AFRICAN AMERICAN HISTORY IS
AMERICAN HISTORY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED WE'RE
GONNA OPEN THE ROLE GO THROUGH
THE ROLE ONCE AND THEN PUT THIS
MATTER ON CALL. MR SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS AYE BATES
HI BEL HI GORGEOUS HI BRADFORD
HI CABALLERO HI JANE. DALLY
DODD HI THERE ALSO HI GALGIANI
HI PLEASE HI GONZALEZ HI GROW.
HERTZBERG HILL- WESSEL HI- TADO
HI JACKSON- JONES LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE MITCHELL HI MONNING-
MORE LOOK HIGH MORALE. HI
NIELSEN HI HI PENN HI
PORTANTINO ROTH HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER. HI STERN OR HI I'M
BURKE HI WHY CAL SKI- WIENER
AYE WILK BY. SENATOR BRADFORD
MOVES A CALL COLLEAGUES WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK NOW TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR AND
SENATOR MITCHELL. AT THE PRO
TEM'S DESK. SENATOR MITCHELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT. IT MUST BE ME ALL
THE MIKES ARE A- NOT BEING
COOPERATIVE TODAY FIRST OF ALL
I'D LIKE TO- THANK OUR
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE SENATE
FOR PARTICIPATING WITH US ON IN
HONORING BLACK HISTORY MONTH
AND ALLOWING THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS TO
RECOGNIZE. SOME CALIFORNIANS
WHO WE ARE I DID A FINE AS
UNSUNG HEROES ARE FORMER
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHERYL BROWN CAME WITH THE IDEA
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO AND EVERY
YEAR SINCE WE'VE IDENTIFIED.
TRUE COMMUNITY LEADERS AND
THERE WE ONLY CONSIDER THEM ON
SONG BECAUSE SOME OF THEM HAVE
NOT ALWAYS RECEIVE THE PUBLIC
RECOGNITION AND ACCOLADES THAT
WE IN THE AFTERMARKET COMMUNITY
CERTAINLY BELIEVE THEY SHOULD
BE ENTITLED TO. WE WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO
INTRODUCE THEM YOU ALL HAVE AT
YOUR DESK A COMMEMORATIVE BOOK-
SO YOU TOO CAN BE INTRODUCED TO
THE UNSUNG HEROES THAT JUST HAD
AN EXPERIENCE ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR SHORTLY BEFORE WE- JOINT
SESSION. YOU KNOW I HAVE THE OF
REPRESENTING- THE SCIENCE
CENTER- IN MY DISTRICT IN THE
THIRTY SENATE DISTRICT. AND AS
I THOUGHT ABOUT MY UNSUNG
HEROES I WANT IDENTIFIED TODAY
I RECOGNIZE THAT YOU KNOW. I
THINK MANY OF YOU IN THIS ROOM.
CAN NAME OFF THE TOP OF YOUR
HEAD. AFRICAN AMERICANS WHO
HAVE EXCELLED IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY
ATHLETICS BUSINESS OTHER AREAS.
BUT I WANTED TO BRING YOUR
ATTENTION TO AN AMAZING CUMPLE.
COOL MADE THEIR MARK ON WORLD
HISTORY. USING MATH SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY. BECAUSE IT WAS A
BLACK MAN WHO CONTRIBUTED TO
THE SUCCESS OF THE APOLLO
ELEVEN WHICH CELEBRATED ITS
FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY THIS WEEK.
HELL WALKER BEGAN HIS CAREER IN
THE LASER TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY A
CONRAD LASER SYSTEM AS A LASER
SYSTEM SPECIALISTS HELP
CONTRIBUTE SIGNIFICANTLY TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE LASER
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY AND HELP
ENHANCE THE FIELD OF STUDY. IT
WAS DUE TO HIS PROMINENCE IN
THIS FIELD THAT HE WAS SELECTED
TO HELP NASA UNDERGO ITS MOST
IMPORTANT EARLY MISSION.
LANDING A MAN ON THE MOON.
ALONG SIDE RENOWNED ASTRONAUT
BUZZ ALDRIN MISTER WALKER
PARTICIPATED ON THE LUNAR LASER
RANGING EXPERIMENT WHICH
CALCULATED THE DISTANCE FROM
EARTH TO THE MOON UTILIZING A
LASER BEAM. REMEMBER COLLEAGUES
FIFTY YEARS AGO. THIS
EXPERIMENT WILL PAVE THE WAY
FOR THE EVENTUAL MOON LANDING
OF BUS AND FELLOW FAMED AFTER
NOT NEIL ARMSTRONG. DR BETTY
DAVIS WALKER IS A FORMER
UNIVERSITY PROFESSOR AND SCHOOL
PRINCIPAL WHO IS MORE THAN
THIRTY YEARS OF EXPERIENCE IN
THE FIELD OF EDUCATION HER
RESEARCH PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON
THE DAMPENING OF OPTIMISM AND
ENTHUSIASM OF LEARNING AND
ACHIEVEMENT. FOR YOUNG BLACK
GIRLS AND BOYS. THROUGH THIS
RESEARCH DOCTOR WALKER IS
ESTABLISH MULTIPLE YOUTH
PROGRAMS IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
HER HUSBAND INCLUDING THE BLACK
MALE ACHIEVEMENT PRAGUE PRAGUE
PROJECT. AND THE ONE THAT'S
HOUSE OF MY DISTRICT CALLED AMY
AN AFRICAN AMERICAN MALE
ACHIEVERS NETWORK ALSO THE
YOUNG LADY'S ACHIEVERS CLUB
WHICH ALL SEEK TO EXPOSE AFTER
AMERICAN CHILDREN. TO THE
IMPORTANCE AND OPPORTUNITIES
WITHIN THE STEM AND STEAM FEELS.
AND AGAIN TO ENHANCE
ACHIEVEMENT AND EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT. TOGETHER HALLEN
BETTY HAVE CONTRIBUTED
SIGNIFICANTLY TO THE REALM OF
SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY NGINEERING
AND MATH AND HAVE MADE SURE TO
UP LIFT AND EXPOSE BLACK
CHILDREN. TO LET THEM KNOW THAT
THEY TOO CAN FOLLOW IN THEIR
FOOTSTEPS. HOW AND BETTY-
PRACTICE WHAT THEY PREACH AND
SPENT A GOOD PORTION F THEIR
TIME DURING THE YEAR ON THE
CONTINENT IN AFRICA. AND OF
COURSE BECAUSE WE WERE GOING TO
RECOGNIZE THEM TODAY THAT'S
WHERE THEY ARE. BUT I AM VERY
PLEASED WITH THEIR DAUGHTER
ALLISON WALKER WAS GRACIOUS
ENOUGH TO JOIN US TODAY TO
ACCEPT THIS UNSUNG HERO AWARD
ON BEHALF OF HER APPEARANCE
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING TO
THE SENATE FLOOR. ALISON WALKER.
COLLEAGUES A WARM WELCOME
PLEASE TO ALISON WORKERS.
COLLEAGUES IF YOU DRAW YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE BACK OF THE
HALL AGAIN IT IS A MATTER OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE I WOULD LIKE
TO. INTRODUCE US SOMEONE WE
SHOULD ALL KNOW AND I'M SUSPECT
ALL DO KNOW SHE WAS ELECTED TO
THE CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX. THE
CALIFORNIA SENATE IN NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT. AND TO THE
CONGRESS OF THE UNITED STATES
IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT.
MURATSUCHI ROLE THE NOTORIOUS
JACKIE SPEAR A WARM WELCOME
PLACE. SENATOR NUMBER DO YOU
HAVE YOUR MIKE UP YOURS YOUR
SITE I WANT TO JOIN- YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT WELCOMING-
CONGRESSWOMAN SPEAR TO THE
FLOOR. CONGRESSWOMAN SPEAR AND
I- WE'RE SEAT MATES FROM
NINETEEN NINETY TO NINETEEN
NINETY THREE I KNOW MANY OF
YOUR THINKING GOLLY GEE THEY
LET HIGH SCHOOL KIDS CERTAINLY
ASSEMBLY THE TIME THAT FLOW-
BUT SHE TAUGHT ME ABOUT BEING A
LEGISLATOR ABOUT. POLITICAL
COURAGE AND ABOUT BEING A
WONDERFUL HUMAN BEINGS SO THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY.
INDEED THANK YOU IN A WARM WARM
CENTER WELCOME TO OUR
COLLEAGUE. AND INSPIRATION FOR
MANY OF US THANK YOU FOR
HONORING US WITH YOUR PRESENCE.
WE ARE ALSO HONORED TO HAVE
WITH US FORMER SENATOR ROD
RIGHT ROD ARE YOU HERE. FRAUD A
WARM WELCOME TO FORMER SENATOR
ROD RIGHT WHO'S WITH US HERE
TODAY. HELLO ALWAYS A PLEASURE
TO SEE YOU SIR. YEAH LAYS IN
GENERAL THE SENATE WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A OFFICIAL PHOTOGRAPH WITH
THE CONGRESS WOMAN. WE'LL TAKE
A QUICK PIES HERE. SENATE
GLAZIER WE PRESENT JEAN IS ACR
IN JUST A MOMENT.
MY COLLEAGUES
THIS IS BEEN WAY TOO MUCH FUN
LET'S GET BACK IF WE COULD TO
ASSEMBLY. THIRD READING WHICH A
SECOND HERE. SENATOR BRADFORD
SURE FOR WHAT PURPOSE. AUG SONG
HEROES ON CERN HEROES PLEASE.
CENTER BRADFORD THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU A CONJECTURE
WE'RE BLESSED HISTORY MONTH I
TO WANT TO RECOGNIZE UNSUNG
HERO AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM LA
STATED IT'S INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE MADE TREMENDOUS
CONTRIBUTIONS TO. THE STATE IN
THE NATION THAT MIGHT NOT
NECESSARY BE RECOGNIZED
UNFORTUNATELY MY- ON A RE TODAY
WAS NOT ABLE TO JOIN US BECAUSE
HE JUST RECENTLY EXPERIENCE HIP
SURGERY. BUT IT'S MY HONOR TO
RECOGNIZE AS MY TWENTY TWENTY
UNSUNG HERO OF THE THIRTY FIFTH
SENATE DISTRICT GILBERT. SMITH
BETTER KNOWN AS GIL SMITH
MISTER SMITH WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN LOS ANGELES KIT WILL
DEAL LIVES IN CARSON FOR THE
LAST FIFTY SEVEN YEARS. HE
GRADUATED FROM MANUAL ARTS HIGH
SCHOOL AND WE'LL SEND YOU
STRAIGHT TECH COLLEGE WHERE HE
PURSUED HIS EARLY CAREER
ASPIRATIONS TO BECAME A ONE OF
THE VERY FEW AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMERCIAL ARTISTS. FOR THE
NEXT TWENTY FOUR YEARS WITH
LIMITED OPPORTUNITIES AVAIL TO
AFTER AMERICANS AT THE TIME HE
WAS VERY SUCCESSFUL. DEAL IS A
RETIRED DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
AND PUBLIC AFFAIRS FOR THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
A GOVERNMENT BETTER KNOWN AS
CáC WHERE HE WAS RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT. OF THE
COURT NEEDED INNER GODDESS
GOVERNMENTAL LEGISLATIVE AND
COMMUNITY RELATIONS PROGRAM HE
WAS A COMMUNITY LEADER FOR THE
SUCCESSFUL CAMPAIGN TO GAIN
APPROVAL FOR THE PRESENT SITE
OF MY ALMA MATER CAL STATE
DOMINGUEZ HILLS. CAL STATE
DOMINGUEZ HILLS GO TOROS. HIS
FIFTY PLUS YEARS OF COMMITMENT
TO CS DO YOU SEE A SHOOT DO YOU
I'M SORRY IS REFLECTED THROUGH
HIS CONTINUED VOLUNTEER SERVICE
AND THE STYLES PRINT OF THE
GILL AND SURELY SMITH'S
SCHOLARSHIP ON THE CAMPUS. IS A
STRONG ADVOCATE FOR ACADEMIC
EXCELLENCE AND OPPORTUNITY AND
ACCESS. HE IS NO STANGER TO
TAKING THE LEAD MISTER SMITH
WAS THE FIRST PRESIDENT OF THE
CITIZENS COMMITTEE FOR THE
INCORPORATION OF THE CITY OF
CARSON. HE SERVED AS A FOUNDING
MEMBER OF THATCOUNCIL FOR
THIRTEEN YEARS HE WAS MAYOR OF
CARSON FROM NINETEEN SEVENTY TO
SEVENTY ONE AND AGAIN FROM
SEVENTY FOUR TO SEVENTY FIVE
ANY SERVICE INTERIM CITY
MANAGER IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT. KILLS THE RECIPIENT OF
MANY COMMUNITY SERVICE AWARDS
AND HE CREDITS HIS LIFELONG
SUCCESS TO HIS FAITH IN GOD.
AND HIS INSPIRATIONAL GUIDANCE
PROVIDED BY HIS PARENTS OUT FOR
A MERRY SMITH HE IS A PROUD
FATHER OF THREE SONS ONE GUARD
OR FIVE GRANDCHILDREN AND NINE
GREAT. GRANDCHILDREN. AGAIN HE
ABLE JOIN US. BUT LACKS
RECOGNIZE THE COMPLIMENTS OF
MISTER GILL SMITH. THANK YOU
SIR BRADFORD AND TO YOU OUR
HONOREE A WARM SENATE.
CONGRATULATIONS ARE THERE ANY
OTHER RECOGNITIONS AT THIS
POINT. SEEING NONE WE WILL MOVE
BACK TO THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE. FILE ITEM TWELVE
SENATOR GLAZER ARE YOU PREPARED.
CENTER GLAZER WILL BE. IF YOU
WISH TO PROCEED WITH THIS ITEM.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
FILE ITEM TWELVE. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE FORTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
RELATIVE TO PHYSICIAN
ANESTHESIOLOGIST WEEK. SENATOR
GLAZERS THANK YOU ARE NOT AN
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT THIS ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW DESIGNATE
SIDE A WEEK THIS OF TWENTY
TWENTY AS PHYSICIAN
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS WEEK. THE
UNITED STATES MORE THAN A
HUNDRED BILLION OPERATIONS YES
A HUNDRED BILLION OPERATIONS
AND PROCEDURES ARE PERFORMED.
WITH ANASTASIA. AND PHYSICIAN
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE IN A PATIENT'S
WELLBEING BEFORE DURING AND
AFTER SURGICAL PROCEDURES. THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS HAVE TAKEN
PROACTIVE STEPS TO PROMOTE
PATIENT SAFETY INCREASE
EDUCATION ABOUT AIN MANAGEMENT
SAFE OPIOID USE AND NON OPIOID
OPS ALTERNATIVES THE PAIN
MANAGEMENT. THIS RESOLUTION
HIGHLIGHTS THE IMPORTANCE OF
PHYSICIAN LED ANESTHESIA CARE
IN PROTECTING PATIENT SAFETY I
RESPECTFULLY ASTRONAUT ABOUT.
THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZER ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS HI BATES HI BEL HI
GORGEOUS- HI BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO HI JANE. DALLY DODD
HI BUT ALSO HI GALGIANI HI
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ GROWS.
HERTZBERG HILL HI HUESO HI
TANTO HI JACKSON HI JONES LEYVA.
HI MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. HI
MONNING HI MORE LOCK. HIGH
MORALE. HI NIELSEN. PAN BY
PORTANTINO HI RALPH BY RUBIO HI
SKINNER. HI STERN HI MOM BURKE.
BY Y. KO SKI. HI WIENER FIVE
WILK. HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME. CHIANG
GROW HERTZBERG JONES NIELSEN HI
SIZE THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO THE OF
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED WE'RE
GONNA MOVE BACK NOW TO THE ITEM
ON CALL FILE ITEM EIGHT ONE
pSECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. CHIANG GROWTH
HERTZBERG JONES. FIVE THIRTY
FIVE NO ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. COLLEAGUES WE ARE NOW
GOING TO GO TO ANNOUNCEMENTS
AND THEN TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS FOR GERMAN IN
MEMORY ARE THERE ANY COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS SENATOR Y. KOWSKI.
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS. AM I
DOING. SENATOR MITCHELL THANK
YOU THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN I
APPRECIATE THAT- COLLEAGUES WE
HAVE A FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE
HEARING IMMEDIATELY UPON A
GERMAN COLLEAGUES TODAY WILL BE
MEETING IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
AGAIN FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE
HEARING ROOM ONE TWELVE. THANK
YOU SENATOR MITCHELL AND THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
ALONG WITH THE SENATE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON WOMEN WORK AND
FAMILIES AND THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS. WILL HOLD AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THE
PINK TAX HOW GENDER BASED
PRICING DISCRIMINATION
UNDERMINES WOMEN'S ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY AND WHAT TO DO
ABOUT IT THAT HEARING WILL BE
HELD IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE.
FIVE MINUTES UPON ADJOURNMENT
OF SESSION ANY OTHER
ANNOUNCEMENTS. SEEING NONE WE
WILL NOW RETURN TO MOTIONS AND
MISSILE RESOLUTIONS ASSIST THE
TIME TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY
SENATOR ATKINS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. YOU KNOW APPROPRIATE
AS WE RECOGNIZE BLACK HISTORY
MONTH- THAT I WOULD ASK MY
COLLEAGUES TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY
OF REVEREND GEORGE WALKER SMITH.
REVEREND SMITH DIED THIS PAST
SATURDAY AT THE AGE OF NINETY
ONE. HE WAS A COMMUNITY I CON
FOR SURE AND ANOTHER ONE OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT WAS
CONSIDERED A RITE OF PASSAGE
FOR ASPIRING PUBLIC SERVANTS.
AND HE WAS SOMEONE THAT I
RESPECTED IMMENSELY. A LONG
TIME RELIGIOUS AND CIVIC LEADER
IN SAN DIEGO HE TOLD YOU
DIRECTLY HOW IT WAS YOU
COULDN'T FULL AMHERST MOVE TALK
HIM HE LOOKED RIGHT INTO YOUR
HEART. WHAT AN INCREDIBLE
LEADER AND WHAT A LOSS MOST OF
US CAN ONLY HOPE TO ONE DAY
ACQUIRE HIS WISDOM. BORN IN
ALABAMA HE WAS A BRILLIANT
STUDENT WHO UNLIKE MOST OF THE
CHILDREN OF SHARE SHARECROPPERS
ATTENDED SCHOOL PASSED THE
NINTH GRADE. HE GRADUATED FROM
KNOXVILLE COLLEGE IN TENNESSEE
GO VOLS. AND THE PITTSBURGH
THEOLOGICAL SEMINARY SCHOOL. IT
WAS AFTER GRADUATING FROM
SEMINARY SCHOOL THAT SMITH
HEADED WEST TO SAN DIEGO IN
NINETEEN FIFTY SIX WITH HIS
WIFE ELIZABETH IRENE TO START A
PRESBYTERIAN CHURCH IN GOLDEN
HILL. A FEW YEARS LATER THE
CONGREGATION YOUR CONGREGATION
MOVED TO YOU CHRIST UNITED
PRESBYTERIAN CHURCH AT
THIRTIETH AND FIRST STREET AND
SOUTH PARK WHICH HE LED FOR
DECADES. HE STARTED THE CACTUS
CLUB A WEEKLY LUNCH MEETING ON
CIVIC AFFAIRS IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY AND IT SOON BECAME AN
INTEGRAL PART OF PUBLIC LIFE IN
THE CITY A MANDATORY STOP FOR
ASPIRING POLITICIANS ELECTED
OFFICIALS. AND THE QUIET POWER
BROKERS IN THE CITY AND YES
THEY SERVED CATFISH. IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX HE WAS
ELECTED PRESIDENT OF THE
NATIONAL SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION I HE WAS ELECTED IN
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE ACTUALLY I
AS THE FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN
ELECTED IN THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO WHEN HE WON A RACE FOR
THE SCHOOL BOARD. HE WAS ON THE
BOARD FOR SIXTEEN YEARS SERVING
AS PRESIDENT FOUR TIMES. HE%
IMMEDIATELY SET TO WORK TO
DIVERSIFY THE DISTRICTS FACULTY
WORKING TO BRING IN NUMEROUS
AFRICAN AMERICAN TEACHERS MANY
OF WHOM ARE RECRUITED FROM HIS
NATIVE SOUTH AND THEN HE WENT
ON TO BECOME PART OF THE
NATIONAL SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION SERVED ON THE
NATIONAL ADVISORY COMMISSION ON
JUVENILE JUSTICE. AND
DELINQUENCY PREVENTION THE
WHITE HOUSE COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION AND THE ARTS THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION THE SAN DIEGO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
BOARD AND THE SAN DIEGO CRIME
COMMISSION HE WAS THE FIRST
PRESIDENT OF THE CITIZENS
ADVISORY REVIEW BOARDS. THAT
MONITORED POLICE PRACTICES IN
THE CITY IN THE MID NINETEEN
EIGHTIES. AS THE SAN DIEGO
UNION TRIBUNE SO APTLY SAID THE
THROUGH LINE IN HIS LIFE WAS
HIS FAITH AND HIS DEDICATION TO
EDUCATION. HE HAD A CLEAR EYED
AND UNCOMPROMISING VIEW OF THE
EVILS OF RACISM AND AN EQUALLY
ABIDING BELIEF THAT IF PEOPLE
SIMPLY COMMITTED TO SPEAKING
WITH EACH OTHER CIVILLY. AND
GOT TO KNOW ONE ANOTHER THEY
WOULD REALIZE THEY WERE FAR
MORE SIMILAR THAN DIFFERENT.
RENDON WALKER SMITH IS SURVIVED
BY HIS DAUGHTER CAROLINE HIS
SON ANTHONY FOR GRAND CHILDREN
A GREAT GRAND SON HE WAS
PRECEDED IN DEATH BY HIS WIFE
ELIZABETH IRENE. AND ANOTHER
DAUGHTER CHOICE SMITH YOU DEL
AND A GRANDSON. THE MAJ SMITH
SO I WOULD ASK YOU TO JOIN ME
IN A DURING IN MEMORY OF
REVEREND GEORGE WALKER SMITH.
THANK YOU SENATOR ATKINS AND
PLEASE EXTEND TO HIS FAMILY THE
CONDOLENCES OF THIS BODY THANK
YOU. SENATOR STERN. I THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE
TO JOURNEY MEMORY OF DOCTOR
MELVIN SEMEN. AN EXTRAORDINARY
MEMBER OF OUR COMMUNITY PASSED
AWAY IN HIS HOME- LAST MONTH HE
WAS BORN IN NINETEEN EIGHTEEN
IN BALTIMORE THE SON OF
IMMIGRANTS. FROM SPAIN HE WAS A
BOY ACTUALLY WHEN THE GREAT
DEPRESSION HIDDEN HELP THIS
PARENTS SURVIVED THAT DARK
PERIOD BY SELLING COPIES OF THE
BALTIMORE SUN ON A STREET
CORNER WITH HIS THREE BROTHERS
IS A TEENAGER- MATHIS HE WENT
BY BEGAN HIS CAREER AS A JUNIOR
HIGH TEACHER IN BALTIMORE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS BUT- AFTER A FEW
YEARS A SERVICE HE RETURNED TO
SCHOOL ON THE JOHNS HOPKINS AND
GETTING HIS PHD IN SOCIOLOGY
FROM- OS YOU. RETURN SOCIAL
PSYCHOLOGY AND WENT BACK TO THE
SAME STREET CORNERS HE WORKED
ON AS A YOUNG MAN TO HELP HIS
FAMILY STAY AFLOAT HE WAS
PROLIFIC FELL IN NINETY SIX
MELVIN WAS GIVEN THE
PRESTIGIOUS COOLEY MEET AWARD
FOR STATE AN HONOR GIVEN ONE
PERSON EACH YEAR FOR A LIFETIME
OF CONTRIBUTION TO THE FIELD OF
SOCIAL PSYCHOLOGY. AND THE
SPEAKER NOTED IN GIVING IN THIS
AWARD THAT THEY WOULDN'T HAVE
NEARLY ENOUGH TIME TO DISCUSS
ALL IS EXTRAORDINARY WORK
BECAUSE FUTURES SOCIOLOGISTS
WERE SO WELL TRAINED OR
MAINTAINED. AS CLOSE TO TOUCH
WITH THE DISCIPLINE IS HEATED.
HE WAS BEST KNOWN FOR STAR
AVAIL. MUCH TO MANY OF THE
TOPICS WE'VE DISCUSSED HERE
TODAY THE SOCIOLOGICAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL IMPACTS THAT A
HISTORY OF RACISM AND
OPPRESSION CAN HAVE ON PEOPLE
HAS VERY SPECIFIC SOCIOLOGICAL
AND PSYCHOLOGICAL IMPACTS ON
INDIVIDUALS AND NO SUCH
SOCIOLOGISTS HAD COVERED THIS
WORK MORE STORE NEARLY THAN
MELVIN DID. A NUMBER OF TITLES
THROUGH HIS LIFE AT UCLA AND IT
WAS YOU CHAIR SOCIOLOGY HE WAS
PRESENT IN THE PACIFIC
SOCIOLOGY ASSOCIATION AND HAD
VISITING PROFESSORSHIPS
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD BUT NONE
OF THESE TITLES WOULD HOLD A
CANDLE TO THE TITLES YOU CHAIRS
MOST HUSBANDS. BROTHER FATHER
AND GRANDFATHER SHORTLY AFTER
WORLD WAR TWO WE MARRIED HIS
WIFE ALICE WITH WHOM WE ARE TO
LOVE FOR DANCING MARYLAND BLUE
CRAB OPERA FRENCH POETRY IN A
GLASS OF WINE SOMETIMES SON
SAID. MELVIN SURVIVED BY HIS
CHILDREN FALL INTO RACER HIS
BROTHER SAM AND GRAND CHILD IS
GRANDSON DAN WHO SERVICES
CABINET SECRETARY FOR GOVERNOR
NEWSOME. AND A GREAT GRANDCHILD
IS TO DO JUST IN A FEW MONTHS
DOCTOR SAME IT WAS A BRILLIANT
KIND MAN HIS CONTRIBUTIONS HAVE
LEFT AN INDELIBLE MARK ON OUR
WORLD TODAY RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT WE OFFER OUR SINCERE
CONDOLENCES FAMILY AND A
JAPANESE. THANK YOU SEE THERE'S
OF COURSE PLAY TO MAKE SURE WE
BRING. A HIS NAME THE FRONT SO
THAT HE CAN BE. MEMORIAL SEEING
NO OTHER RETURN IN MEMORIES AND
IF THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS
SENATOR ATKINS. THE DESK IS
CLEAR THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
LET ME JUST START REMIND MY
COLLEAGUES THAT. DODD TOMORROW
AT TEN THIRTY IS THE STATE OF
THE STATE AND IF MY COLLEAGUES
WOULD LIKE TO START BY.
GATHERING AT TEN AM WE WILL I
HEAD OVER TO THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBERS TOGETHER. I ALSO WANT
TO SAY A VERY HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO
OUR FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE THE
SENATOR FROM FREE MINE TODAY.
AND WITH THAT OUR NEXT
SCHEDULED SESSION WILL BE
THURSDAY FEBRUARY TWENTIETH AT
NINE AM THANK YOU MADAM THANK
YOU SENATOR AND THE BIRTHDAY TO
SENATOR Y. KOWSKI. COLLEAGUES
WE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE
WE RECONVENE THURSDAY. AT NINE
AM.